mieux elle jospin a choisi d'interrompre
ses vacances en egypte et s'est rendu
aujourd'hui dans plusieurs endroits
d'île de france touchée par la tempête
notamment dans l'essonne et les yvelines
il a également visité la caserne des
pompiers de paris porte de champerret
afin de porter témoignage de
l'efficacité des services publics
il a annoncé que l'état allait aider les
communes qui seront dans des situations
particulières
catherine de l'engin lionel jospin sur
le terrain pour mesurer l'ampleur des
dégâts causés par la tempête
première étape de cette tournée en
ile-de-france la forêt de dourdan où
plusieurs milliers d'arbres ont été
arrachés même spectacle de désolation un
peu plus tard à versailles et puis le
premier ministre s'est rendu sur
l'autoroute a13 toujours fermée à la
circulation
une visite pour témoigner aussi de la
solidarité de l'état à l'égard des
victimes et les rassurer quant à leur
indemnisation
depuis la loi 90 toute personne touchée
par un sinistre qui dans les cinq jours
adresse l'évaluation de ce sinistre à sa
compagnie d'assurance eux tous
automatiquement couverts pour quasiment
l'ensemble des dégâts à 99% dans ces
situations de tempête ou de ou de
cyclone
et par ailleurs nous déclencherons la
procédure de catastrophe naturelle à
chaque fois qu'elle sera utile pour le
complément à la demande de des communes
l'état de catastrophe naturelle sera
donc étudier au cas par cas